pourquoi tu ramènes panne et chocolat
demain au collège et puis tu engages la
conversation mais pour un bouffon coi
s'inquiète enfin le problème fait déjà
les choux est mort je suis pas ce qu'ils
font ça fait une semaine que tu as en
cour prévu de faire des copains quand
même mais bon j'étais tout seul quand
même dans son royaume et j'ai ma propre
cette maison j'ai rien à voir à
l'inversé pour une dispo clair on va
faire une énorme taf d'accord tous les
petits gars de jeu qui sera bourré
joindre à la foule lui a tout mon client
dirigé par la victoire
est ce renouvellement aussi beaucoup
voilà pourquoi tu ne vas pas te sens la
soirée on pourrait faire semblant de
s'intéresser à lui oui mais comment je
vais faire quoi il a rendez-vous et tu
te pointes avec une autre fille des
meubles qu'on me suis rangé alouettes
deviennent folles souffler un peu moins
derrière ça les commentateurs un des
gros nichons bien fait c'est qu'il faut
faire
est-ce que 6,9 un fait exprès de ne
jamais me paraît est ce que je pourrais
singe peut qu'elles utilisent cette
technique la jaloux parce qu'en fait tu
es amoureux de moi non